right the Food and Drug Administration
we're moving on is launching its first
TV ads to fight vaping by teenagers the
FDA is nearly 60 million dollar
initiative is called the real cost so
this includes new commercials featuring
street magician
Julius Dean who uses tricks to educate
teens on the risk of e-cigarettes you
got vape with you babe I'm gonna put it
in your hand like this ready for this
watch the vape here we go you just went
from vaping to trying cigarettes you're
more likely to start smoking cigarettes
I don't want to hear that but I hear you
don't want to hear it don't want to hear
it but he hears it the Centers for
Disease Control says more than one in
five high school students in nearly one
in twenty middle school middle schoolers
rather vape for high school students
that's about 78% increase Wow
between 2017 and 2018 tomorrow and
Thursday a house oversight subcommittee
will look into the role of the
e-cigarette maker jewel in this team
nicotine epidemic anti vaping advocates
and representatives of jewell are
expected to give testimony in a
statement to CBS News a jewel
spokesperson said quote we share the
subcommittee's concerns about youth
vaping and welcome the opportunity to
appear and share information about our
commitment to eliminate combustible
cigarettes and our aggressive
industry-leading actions to combat youth
usage CTM consumer investigative
correspondent and a Werner has been
looking into the impact of teen vaping
and our doctor Tara nurullah is a
cardiologist good morning to you both
the perfect people we have on this on
this subject Tara let's remind people at
the outset what are the known risks of
e-cigarettes for teenagers well the
beauty of these ads as you saw is that
they're telling kids that this is not
something that's cost free or low risk
there can be devastating consequences
and 80% of kids don't recognize that
there can be harm so first and foremost
the e-cigarettes can be a gateway to
traditional cigarette use we know that
kids who use e-cigarettes four times
more likely to go on to smoke
traditional cigarettes then let's talk
about the nicotine the nicotine one of
the most addictive substances known to
man
if it has effects on the adolescent
brain which develops until the mid-20s
it can affect memory and learning it can
impact impulse control it can increase
the risk for mood disorders and it can
prime the brain for addiction to other
substances nicotine can have
cardiovascular effects raising blood
pressure and heart rate the ultrafine
particles and the flavorings can damage
the lungs
there have been tar cinah jhin's toxins
heavy metals found in these east
cigarettes and then we've heard about
the explosions that can happen the
accidental ingestion they've always said
all along that it was never targeted for
kids but you see flavors like strawberry
lemon-aid strawberry milk mango jewel
didn't have flavors like bubble gum and
cotton candy but other people did so it
seemed like it was very deliberate for
teenagers so what would this FDA push do
now well that's the question so if you
talk to advocates and parents groups who
have set up to oppose cigarettes and
particularly Jul they will tell you that
the FDA has talked a good game but not
done enough in terms of regulation in
fact this month the campaign for
tobacco-free kids which is a prime group
going after a cigarette problems in
general had sued and a judge had ruled
that the FDA had to move up its
timelines for regulations of these
products you know the products are
already on the market they kind of got
an exception yes you can be on the
market but we're going to take a look at
you you're gonna have to submit
applications sort of after the fact in a
sense and advocates and activists are
saying look they're not moving fast
enough it's nice for them to put out a
couple TV ads they don't really think
it's gonna make any difference
kids are already doing their own social
media do it for Jul and you know like
all kinds of Julie experiments and Jul
as we know is the gorilla in the March
so you don't think this latest push will
really make a difference well that you
have to listen to the parents who are
dealing with the kids and the activists
were looking at teen addiction and what
they'll tell you is look teens already
know about it it's already out there and
they believe many of these kids that we
spoke to in interviews believe well it's
okay because it's less harmful than
cigarettes yeah yeah they have this
impression which is something that for
adults it might be better than smoking
an actual cigarette but the teens have
also kind of gotten that message and
they think this is fun it's cool I was
looking at the CDC numbers just before
coming on and we mentioned these seven
a percent increase in teens using
e-cigarettes 2017 to 2018 very
interesting that there was not an
increase in teen traditional cigarette
use in that time so while the risk of
going over to the to the really bad evil
thing is possible it doesn't seem like
it's happening yet I'm interested from
the anti tobacco warriors from recent
decades those groups are still around
are they heartened at least by that
number I don't think any of them who are
trying to work on this problem are
particularly heartened by anything at
this point I think what you'll hear them
say is there's an epidemic of teens
using these products as you pointed out
Tara there are all these either real or
potential health consequences and
addiction addiction The effect of
nicotine on the young developing brain
is is key to what they're looking at and
they're basically saying you know on
this one the horse got out of the barn
yeah so so Tara what can a parent do if
they realize their kid is vaping and how
do you know if they are great question I
mean parents need to be educated about
this they need to have their eyes wide
open and be vigilant because these
devices can be easily concealed they can
look like flash drives some parents have
said look I found this in my kids
backpack for months and I thought it was
a part of a toy they don't produce a lot
of odor they don't have a lot of smoke
so parents need to start talking to
their kids in elementary school about
the potential health risks of
e-cigarettes they need to be asking them
as they get older are you using do you
know kids who are using why are you
using and if their kid is becoming
addicted they need to help them get help
and not punish them because this is a
real addiction and also counseled them
on how to avoid peer pressure situations
some of the signs parents can look for
stomach aches headaches changes in
behavior lack of concentration
irritability might prompt you to ask
your kid is something going on really
really good advice really great
reporting thank you both very much